faire l'épicerie n'est pas pour
plusieurs d'entre nous l'activité la
plus agréable et ce même si les
détaillants et les grandes chaînes
proposent de nombreuses innovations
j'en discute avec isabelle marquis
nutritionniste et spécialiste de la mise
en marché de produits alimentaires
depuis un an notre façon de faire
l'épicerie a bien changé évidemment on a
commencé pour plusieurs affaires de
lipsheim en ligne on a on vous êtes
moins de magasins ont fait une plus
grosse épicerie ont fait des réserves et
pas juste de papier toilette mais bien
avant la pandémie la transformation
était déjà en cours en effet vous avez
probablement remarqué sur au cours des
deux dernières années environ mise en
scène particulièrement de l'entrée des
supermarchés avaient commencé à changer
passablement l'espace qui est dédié aux
mains prêtes à manger prête à cuisiner
c'est s'est décuplée cette
transformation l'un était motivée par
plein de feuilles de statistiques
notamment le fait que comme canadien
mais on voulait passer de moins en moins
de temps à cuisiner on cuisine est de
moins en moins et on dépense est aussi
de plus en plus dans les restos tout ça
ce sont les conditions gagnantes dans le
fond pour motiver nos distributeurs
alimentaires à revoir leur modèle et à
nous proposer quelque chose qui
ressemble un peu à un hybride entre la
restauration et la distribution puisque
les spécialistes ont baptisé grosses
frites donc mariage des mots grosses
truites et restera post-pandémie jusqu
où est-ce qu'on est rom mais ce qui est
certain c'est que cette tendance là pour
une offre plus variée et plus importante
de même prête à manger en supermarché va
continuer de se développer
ça c'est certain il ya un secteur en
alimentation qui est pas très développée
c'est le secteur technologique on
commence quand même à voir apparaître
certaines choses un peu partout ici et
ailleurs
honnêtement il ya une explosion de
développement technologique concerne le
secteur agroalimentaire et qui ont une
influence sur tous les aspects de notre
alimentation de nous deux
très près de nous les applications des
applications à utiliser son téléphone
mobile
deux exemples concrets que je vous
donnerai yucca et l'open fou de facts
qui est une base de données
attaché à l'application de lutherie
score c'est une meilleure base de
données internationale qui nous donne
j'oserais dire le petit gris ou le
portrait détaillé de chacun des aliments
et qui nous donne une indication hyper
simple et claire est ce que ça vaut la
peine d'un point de vue santé en tout
cas d'acheter ce produit là ou pas on
essaie des plantes actuellement deux
côtés d'italie par exemple c'est un
supermarché ou en place notre main au
dessus des aliments et l'eau sur un
écran apparaît le descriptif complet la
provenance les valeurs nutritives et ses
terrasses pire même fabuleux concept
fantastique un petit bijou de
technologie au lieu de vendre le concept
a été lancé dans le cadre de l'expo
universelle en 2015 et il y à une
intégration des technologies
partout vous avez un peu partout dans le
supermarché des écrans tactiles entre
autres donc qui vous permettent de
repérer un produit souhaité avoir une
vous savez pas aux mines et de comparer
deux produits et quand je dis comparer
c'est comparer sur tous les aspects pas
juste le prix et le prix par 100 g la
composition la valeur nutritive la
provenance le niveau de transformation
est ce qu'il ya des certifications
alouettes n'importe quoi tout est là ici
au canada il ya quand même deux
expériences qui sont actuellement le
faire mieux pas ni intelligent dont on
parle depuis si longtemps où on place
des objets et puis on saura la caisse
puis on veut au fur et à mesure notable
de notre facture puis des enfants il ya
quelque chose qui se fait en ontario
puis à quelque chose qui se fait à
montréal aussi dans l'espèce
d'automatisation de notre passage à
l'épicerie
si un moment je pense à l'épicerie qu'on
aime particulièrement peau c'est celui
d'attendre à en ligne pour passer à la
caisse s'est tous battu le verbe est un
mal nécessaire
mais plutôt que de dire ça comme ça ça
fait déjà quelques années qu'on nous
propose dks de le brusquer d'hébreu
service où on va scanner nous mêmes nos
produits mais il ya certains marchands
qui ont décidé d'essayer d'aller plus
loin
c'est le cas entre autres d'amazon go
aux états unis concept de petite
épicerie où on entre et on sort comme on
entrerait il sortirait dans le métro
vous prenez votre téléphone vous le
mettez sur la borne en rentrant vous
êtes automatiquement identifiés ou
ramasser tout ce que vous voulez sur des
tablettes et vous sortez c'est ce que
fait entre autres couster en ce moment
dans un magasin test sur le campus de
l'université mcgill à montréal
l'idée c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
connaît du plaisir parce que faire son
épicerie je connais beaucoup de gens qui
aiment vraiment à ça non plus plusieurs
travaillent et réfléchissent à revoir
l'expérience et a essayé de faire de
l'épicerie une destination agréable un
endroit où on a hâte d'aller et non pas
juste un mal nécessaire comme c'est le
cas bien des fois certains exemples que
j'ai vu entre autres aux états unis où
évidemment parle près pandémie des
épiciers qui avait intégré un espace
lounge pour aller se détendre et relaxer
lire la circulaire écouter de la musique
passé le temps peu importe un espace
café un bar à café avec des baristas
donc c'est certain que ce phénomène là
vaut continuer notamment parce que j'ai
envie de dire qu avec ce qu'on vit là je
pense que le volet humain lié à
l'alimentation et à tout le processus
d'achat nous manque
d'ailleurs on le voit avec la montée en
popularité qui a eu durant la pandémie
de tout le commerce de proximité
nos petits boulangers nos petits
bouchers on a eu envie de se rapprocher
de retourner voir ces gens là vous de
les découvrir si on ne les connaissait
pas alors tout ça c'est inscrit dans la
même veine les grands supermarchés vont
devoir continuer d' user de créativité
et d'ingéniosité pour rendre le lieu de
vente agréable et plus humain merci
isabelle bond épicerie à l'épicerie